good morning it's now 10:01 a.m. so I'm
going to go ahead and open the
subcommittee work session on house Bell
362 FN which is relative to complaint
procedures and cases before the
commission for human rights and we'll
Allegiance I to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for it stands one nation under God
all since our name tags are missing
today for anybody uh watching I'm going
to just let everybody know who everybody
is down at the end we have rep
Horgan next to him is rep Manos I'm rep
end so to start I'd like to uh kind of
see what the committe is thinking I
don't see anybody in the audience that
we haven't already heard from so uh
I'd like to see where the committee is
at I know we met the last time we got
some new information and I just I want
to see what everybody's thoughts are at
this
point there anybody who might like to go
first
rep rep Andrew and then rep
Deo thank you madam
chair my concern
is the human rights commit
and I don't think throwing money at it
is the total answer we have to do better
for the
public the fact that it's taking several
years sometimes for a case to
finish somehow we need to speed it up I
right Lorenzo thank you madam chair I
would like to go back to the original um
bill
and the original bill was a Senate Bill
correct that
um are you talking about the SB 216 yes
sb216 and the original bill was
to allow
the complainant only to remove the case
Court
okay so you're T okay so are you talking
about the initial bill that um you and
rep Smith and rep yes it was 362 362
okay I didn't know if you were referring
to the Senate bill from the year before
when you said SB so that's why I was oh
okay I got confused okay okay um and did
you have any thoughts on it or you're
just saying that that's the that's what
you would prefer to move forward with um
I think I I wanted to just mention that
that was the original intent of the bill
um and since then we found other other
issues with um Human Rights Commission
and we do have a
um a performance audit in that's being
done now and I was wondering if we
should wait until the performance audit
is completed before we make any
decisions thank so uh just to give a
little information I did contact the LBA
audit division yesterday just to get us
stus and see when we may get that they
informed me that they would they
wouldn't be able to complete the audit
until about mid-February plus or minus a
month and so this bill we would have to
act on by November
17th however rep Smith let me know that
when the LBA audit is completed it will
go to the finance committee and at that
point the and correct me if I'm wrong
please the finance committee could go
before the rules committee to put in
necessary uh thank you for um
recognizing me I'm not on the
subcommittee although of course I am on
on the full committee um the uh the LBA
reports to the fiscal committee that's
where they report and um they have been
asked asked to do a performance audit
not a financial audit performance audit
they will submit that
report to the fiscal committee once the
fiscal committee accepts it which they
will do immediately upon
receip then it is in the possession of
the house and at that point it would be
anybody but it would be appropriately
this committee the house judiciary
committee that could go to the rules
committee and if they so chose and to
say information has come to us that was
not available during the um the regular
period for filing bills and um it came
as a result of the performance audit and
we have two choices I mean the first is
to say we think that there are steps
that could be and should be taken
immediately in in order to best meet the
needs of the citizens of the state and
therefore we would like permission for a
bill um and we would I mean if we could
get it and act on it by the end of March
we don't even have to suspend rules on
the floor of the house um the other
alternative is we say to this committee
um we now have the results of the
performance audit that the previous
Judiciary Committee asked
for we know this has been going on a
long time but the problems have been
going on
longer and um we would like to have an
informal group from the Judiciary
Committee and I would hope from the
public um uh you know the there are a
number of different components in the
public who have vested interest in this
to shape a
bill that we could then file for the
next term so we have
two alternative approaches that way and
I
um I of course would support the major
what the majority of the subcommittee
and the committee would like to do um I
have a vote I guess only on the full
committee but my vote there would be to
say rather than uh put a Band-Aid on um
a little little scratch that we
see um that we ought to wait and see
what the performance audit says I
believe the performance audit will end
up identifying a
series of of places that we could help
make the human uh Rights Commission
better meet its obligations and that's
our role um so I I don't I don't
particularly see going to all the effort
to to address one
small I don't mean
insignificant but small problem
in light of the major
concerns thank
you rep Manos and then rep Morgan thank
you I I see value in doing that and
waiting for the for the um the audit to
come back I am concerned about what
happens to complainants in the meantime
and leaving the issue unaddressed but I
think there are enough issues that we
can wait for the audit and address
everything at
once
um so I think that's my
preference to do that to approach it
that
way again um yes I uh also agree that we
should wait for the audits I don't think
there's much legislative we can do uh
you know this fall fall about it I um
because the original impetus behind the
bill was just right now either the
complaintant or the respondent can
appeal to the superior court and um it's
not really a huge we did get a memo with
a number of cases it's not a huge number
of cases so like it's um not going to
affect the court system that much one
way or another if we add or subtract
those cases to their their workload but
um and the reason and also I I found the
uh file the pill file which is online
from the uh way back in 2000 which
before I was in the legislature there
were a couple familiar names involved in
it like uh Senator uh dad Gordon who was
our chair until uh last last year till
last session was involved in it and
Sandy resent Sandy ke who was also a
longtime member of the committee until
about three or four years ago so it's uh
um this has been the impetus behind uh
the original bill I think just said just
the complainant uh could appeal the
courts which is how it is with most such
proceedings and that was the purpose of
bill to make it that way and but the
very original Bill submitted way back in
2000 said that and then they added the
respondent basically as part of uh to
get a compromise to get something that
could go through both houses both
legislative Chambers and it passed
apparently fairly easy judging by the
docket so um even though I think in
theory the original version of this bill
is an improvement um I think it's
probably tolerable the way it is and
this uh particular institution
Commission on human rights it's not
functioning perfectly but it's
functioning better than a lot of
equivalent agencies elsewhere in state
government so I think we may have
stumbled on something that's you know
endemic to many many boards and
commissions throughout the state
government and nothing unique to this um
organization which uh could be
functioning better but it seems to be
functioning uh reasonably well under the
under the with the resources available
to and and all things so I think so I'm
not sure if we need any amendments or
legislation right now but we do need to
keep an eye on the performance audit and
possibly introduce legislation if we can
based on that and
that that's probably correct Their
forance audience won't be there until
the spring of 2024 sometime so that's
where I'm coming from on
that thank you
roran
um yes rep mad chair may I ask a
question sure I think I'm having a
senior moment so please bear with me is
it this
bill or is it another where we had hoped
that some of the attorneys involved in
each traditional
side uh we going to get together to see
if they could come up
with a suggestion for how to move
forward and and I'm now confused as to
whether it was this bill or another can
you help me it was this bill and I know
that attorney Burns reached out to
attorney
daragon um and
I correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
attorney daragon said we don't really
want to compromise right now we want to
wait for the LBA audit to be completed
statement there's a red light is that on
okay thank you very much just to clarify
it is true that attorney Heather Burns
one of my my um esteemed colleagues she
contacted me to see for that very
purpose and it was
considered um that this audit still has
to come to full
fruition and my response to her was just
that let's see how the audit plays out
let's get that information that data and
then take it from there
thank you so sorry
um could you please identify yourself oh
yes my name is Beth Daran I'm an
employment lawyer and I'm employed at
past story crayons here in conquered New
Hampshire thank you so I did want to
point out just to the to thank you I
appreciate it to the committee to the
subcommittee
that last year there was a subcommittee
who kind of deep dived into this and as
a result of that
subcommittee there was a decision and a
to move forward with the LBA audit
however there was also a decision to
move forward with this bill and it
wasn't thought that this bill was going
to correct the
over the overall issue it was taking one
slice of a piece that
was considered unjust or
unfair and bringing that piece forward
and then letting the LBA audit play out
concurrently so this was never meant to
solve the bigger picture and I just I
want to make sure that we're considering
that piece of it because I think they're
two separate issues this was never this
for my understanding this bill wasn't
put forward to solve the overarching
issue and I do want to note that like
rep Horgan I did pull up the meeting
minutes or the committee minutes from
2000 when this was put in and even back
in 2000 and there was a big issue with a
backlog of cases and there was cases
that attorneys had testified were four
to 5 years old so this is not a new
issue and I would say that obviously
that didn't start just in in 2000 so
this issue's been going on for more than
25 years and I'm not sure exactly how
long it's been going on but at least 25
years
so I'm not sure that it's something that
we're going
to fix overnight but I I would
say you know that I when we went in June
information we were informed you know at
that time that the oldest open case had
been that of
2020 is that correct
2022 um and then when we came back here
in the
fall we were informed well that just
meant the oldest case that was awaiting
to be insigned to an investigator but
not the oldest pending case and so I
think this committee had
was at least I will say that I felt a
little bit misled because I I went into
the summer thinking okay maybe that's
not the pro maybe it's not a problem
anymore maybe things are fixed and then
come to find out they weren't fixed and
so at this point it's
difficult to kind of go back in time and
be like how can we try and fix that
think I mean does anybody feel
that this sliver of a piece should be
fixed at all before we move forward with
the overall fixing that needs to be done
with the LBA audit or does everybody
feel we shouldn't try and fix any piece
it um I believe that representative Lynn
has an amendment is that correct and
would it my question would be um can
that Amendment be proposed to the
subcommittee or do we have to wait for
the um for the whole committee to meet
to consider that Amendment so we could
look at it um um however I did I did
speak uh with some of the employee
attorneys and they actually felt like
that Amendment would make things worse
they'd prefer just it Ling it and the
reason why is because for a pray party
to have their case pulled before the
investigation is complete they'd be on
the hook financially to pay for some
sort of a private investigation because
at that point if you're pulling out
after 60 days or I mean after um six
months plus or minus that or plus that
TW month period you're talking eight
months at that point the investigation
completed so
um that that being said does anybody
table
entertaining so um if we want to OTP it
if we want to OTP with some sort of
amendment or if we want to itl it I
think would be the proper motions before
us I would say itl does anybody second
that
second I I'll second it if no one else
yeah okay
um I guess then do we want
to vote on that all in favor if you want
to raise your hand if you're in favor of
it
Ling are you
opposed are you opposed to Elling okay
all
right
um three to two
um so I we bring forward this
recommendation to the main committee I
would like to
say you know that one of the big
principles that we've
always discussed as a committee is just
as delayed as just as denied and I I
really strongly
feel that what's happening right now is
not good and not just for for the
citizens of New Hampshire we need to do
better
waiting for years to get Justice is just
completely
unacceptable I understand that there
were reasons why and that this has been
when we went there were five
investigators at the time one has now
one uh is no longer there now and so and
there were four four new investigator
positions that were put into the budget
so there's now five investigator
positions and those haven't even been
posted yet so we've got to move forward
with something and I I hope that this
committee will not have to micromanage
these things but we're certainly
prepared to do so if we have to it's I
think it's very important that those
requisitions are are posted at once and
that we really work and move forward to
getting caught up on the backlog of
cases because it just it's unacceptable
for the citizens of New Hampshire and we
can't let things continue on this way
does anybody else have anything they'd
like to
say rep Anderson then rep
deeno thank you madam chair the reason I
oppose this is is because I feel that if
we pass this bill it's a small step
forward and I agree with you we need to
do something for the people of New
Hampshire I totally agree that as far
as the performance audit and that end of
it we have to
wait but we can't keep my thing is we
can't keep kicking the ball down the
road and not going forward and making
things better for the people of New
Hampshire that have legitimate claims
and you know I just think we have to do
better and I hope no matter what that
this Human Rights Commission what's the
problems aren't dropped and put on a
back burner somewhere
because I
think it's a the commission is a
challenge and we need to get it
you
lzo Rett
Manos the reason that I voted um itl is
because I think the um the the bill
creates a due process argument which I
think is a serious concern and that if
you take away um if you give only the
complainant the right to remove I think
you create a due process argument um so
that's why I voted to itl but I also
wanted to say that I completely agree
with you rep katab on the issue about
the Human Rights Commission having new
resources now to hire additional
investigators additional staff and
frankly I find it very very very
concerning that the commission hasn't
moved forward with um posting those
openings and engaging in the process of
hiring new people new staff so um I want
to urge also that the that that that
process be engaged and and be followed
through
on mam sh would we be able to would we
be able to um speak with a witness right
now um the executive director an
Malachi sure sure um
if director Malachi would you be willing
to come up I think do did you have a
yes good morning good morning Miss
Malachi it's great to see you again my
my question is around the relationship
between the Human Rights Commission and
the Attorney General's office and I see
the Attorney General's office as the
Civil Rights division how closely do
does the commission for human rights and
the Attorney General's office
work um there are opportunities for us
to work closely together uh the Civil
Rights unit specifically at the doj has
um jurisdiction over 354a which is the
Human Rights Commission stat
as well as 354b which deals with hate
crimes
so we we don't necessarily work together
on a particular case uh but we can work
together if need be okay so followup so
does the um civil rights division have
um do they
have do they supervise the Human Rights
Commission they do not we are a separate
entity and there's one attorney in the
Civil Rights unit okay and then may I
ask another question yes you may so now
your office is moving correct correct
where are they moving to um the GNC just
approved our lease yesterday so we are
moving to 57 Regional Drive which is
around the corner from where we are and
it has uh almost triple the space that
we have right now oh terrific do you
find the space that you work in adequate
to the for the job that you need to do
it's inadequate for the number of people
that we will have okay so there's no
there are no other offices no space MH
so now geographically how close is your
office to the Attorney General's office
um I'm not exactly sure how many miles
away so right now we're we're on two
Industrial Drive um and then we're
moving around the corner to Regional but
the doj is moving further away and
they're moving to one Granite place I
believe I think next week is when
they're moving actually um so I'm I'm
not exactly sure maybe it's a 10-minute
drive a give or take
I don't know I guess what I'm getting at
is I think it would be it would be great
if you all worked within the same
complex it would have been great that
was uh something the governor thought
about having us at Granite place but it
didn't work out so I had to make other
arrangements thank you when is that
lease set to start at the no it's set to
start November 1st uh but it will be a
little bit longer than that before we're
in there uh doit is working on cabling
right now um because the lease has been
sign the landlord can do carpet and all
those things and then that gives me an
opportunity to um to move forward with
some of the things that I was waiting on
because we'll have a place for everyone
to be we'll have computers yada yada so
do you think that in the meantime that
you'd be able to when are you or when do
you anticipate posting the job recks for
the new investigators as soon as
possible okay so as as in now not not as
soon as possible after the November 1
lease signing soon the leases the lease
is approved so we're definitely going
there everything is set um the doj is
moving next week so I'd have to
coordinate um they assist us with the
back of house things so job postings
accounts receivable accounts um payable
Etc so I just need to manage what that
looks like in terms of having things
posted uh but I mean that's not a a huge
hill to climb so okay perfect I did see
that they did post some new Rex this
week so it seems as if they are still
posting Rex maybe here and there
yeah poran oh you're we Vis I think most
of us around the many of us around the
table visited your office and you were
doing a good job in there but it was a
rather snug fit so like I'm so I'm glad
to hear that you'll have more space to
spread out it and move around in so
thanks so I have another question from
Miss Malachi do you feel that the
software that you that you're using now
is adequate for the job that you're
doing
um that's a good question so um reports
are written in word so you know that's
not really cumbersome um what we are
working on or what I'm working on um
simultaneously is um a contract with a
vendor to establish a case management
system so right now what we have is a
series of word uh word and um Excel
documents to to do our tracking um we do
have a a case management system that we
use right now with through the EEOC
which belongs to them so it's the
federal governments they make it
available to all of the states that have
contracts with them so that's awesome
however um there's some reporting tools
that we don't have access to so that's a
whole another long story um and so
having our own case management system
although yes it would duplicate efforts
but it will allow us to have um all of
the statistical information that we need
it would allow us to have all of the
historical data that we have compiled
over time and allow us to move away from
spreadsheets and have something that is
21st century yes uh thank you um for
your answer um can I just follow up um
do you go to like Regional or state um
conferences on for human rights
commissions like your like your own um
is there a trade group
so um there are two answers to that
question so the EEOC annually does have
a National Conference which um all the
states participate and I have
participated every year uh since I
started which was in 2018 and during
coid those were virtual so we you know
participated virtually and then I don't
know if all the regions have a Regional
Conference excuse me but the New England
region which is region one we do have a
Regional Conference and I've
participated in those since 2018 as well
we just had um the last one was in uh
Saratoga Springs New York and it was
towards the end of
September so is there any type of canned
software from vendors that you could use
that other um agencies are using human
rights agencies are using um no because
everyone's using something different so
um Massachusetts the their commission um
they've estab they've built their own
software which is maybe 20 or so years
old um some entities use Salesforce some
use Civ crrm uh Maine uses that one
which that's who I'm engaging with uh to
to have um it's an open source software
more information than you want to know
but to the short answer is everyone does
something a little different there isn't
just one thing other than the software
that the EEOC provides and we have to
use that in order for them to track our
case process processing um for payment
but they also allow us because most
states don't have the money to have a
separate case management system so they
do allow us to put all of our
information in there the caveat to that
is if they change systems which they did
in 20122 we run the risk of losing
historical data um but you know that
kind of Is What It Is Well you certainly
have some challenges thank you so much
for your responses one one final uh
thing so when the
or I guess while the LBA audit is still
being complete would you completed would
you be willing to try and come up with
some recommendations or ways that we may
be able to help this
committee expedite the cases you know so
that we don't have cases from from 2019
I mean it in my mind you know the having
Speedy Justice would mean definitely
less than a year from from start to
completion
um and so could you try and come up with
some ways that you think that we may be
able to get to that point um so thank
you for that question um and to speak
specifically about the 2019 that's one
case and that's one of the ones that was
on the list um because of a bankruptcy
so we have to stay our work because of
the bankruptcy court and that's what
they're saying we have to do um so back
to answering your question um I'd be
happy to do that but what I would prer
if I could um I think it would be
more meaningful to have a one-on-one
conversation whether it's one of you or
a couple of you to walk through because
the problem
that I see from this side of the of the
table is there's a a a multitude of
information that you all have received
over the past three years there's a lot
of it um however there are things that
have been stated that are very dis
ingenuous and so yes this case may have
taken this long or that long but the
attorneys are not telling you that they
went on vacation for a month and we had
to wait or that they um after a
summation letter was sent then they
decided to amend a charge which then the
other side has to answer to so that
extends the time that it takes to
complete an investigation additionally
um the attorneys that practice before us
which are many and you've seen that on
the last email that I sent you these are
practice attorneys and if they have an
idea that it may take a little while for
us to get to them there's absolutely no
reason why they don't have affidavits
and other things that they would do in a
regular court case to put information to
give us the information to preserve
whatever it is that they feel is
important for their client regardless of
whether it's a complainant or a
respondent and those things are options
that they have all the time they've
always had those options and you know
I'm not a lawyer but I can use a few
terms you know there's some attorneys
who will do motion practice in front of
us this one has a motion then you have
to wait for the other side then this one
makes a motion and you have to wait for
the other side and then this one wants
to make an amendment and then you have
to wait for the other side so those are
elements that are part of this that it's
not a plus or 1+ 1al 2 sometimes it's
1.1 + 2 = 3.5 so I think making the
rule because we should live in the rules
and not live in the exception however I
believe that having a more detailed
conversation where it's not a 30-minute
meeting so that there's a a bigger
understanding of what it is that we do
then it makes sense to bring some ideas
forward and have that conversation which
I'm extremely open to doing and want to
do that um and that could be done
tomorrow right we don't have to wait for
the LBA audit to finish um to have those
conversations and then we can make those
changes we can delay the changes until
the audit is done or get started on
whatever you all think is a great idea
and then we can also still make changes
complete um I'm gonna take rep Smith in
a second I just I would be very open to
doing that I think as long as we don't
have a quorum of people not meeting
however I think we need
to we would need to see what specific
things are kind of rules ver statues but
um go ahead rep Smith
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for your candid approach um I want to
begin before I address what you've just
said I want to go back to um something
my colleague representative Andrew said
early on and I think she's absolutely
no rest of us voted well I didn't vote
but you you voted yes and yet her reason
for voting no is absolutely legitimate
she sees the legislator's
responsibility to do everything in our
power to make the Human Rights
Commission best meet the needs of the
citizens of the state and sooner rather
than later is what we all should be
doing so I agree with her premise
completely where I disagree is that I
think we have been at this for a long
time I say this having been in the
legislature since 1996 I know what a
long time is and um we haven't been able
to get it right yet and I fear that if
we pass legislation that addresses one
very
small issue in a very long list of
serious problems
we conceivably make it possible for
people to say well you already did
something so let's go on to other issues
and I think we cannot put this off any
longer we have to address this in a way
that is complete I think that is why um
under uh the previous subcommittee's
chair uh chairmanship representive
McLean's chairmanship he moved to ask
the one
agency that's
available to the legislature to do the
best possible job he went to ask the
legislative audit committee to not just
you know look at a little bit here at a
little bit there but do a performance
audit of the
agency and we need to see how all the
pieces fit together it's not like each
of us takes a different position on the
elephant and says oh look this is all
about a tail or this is all about a
trunk this is about the entire human
relations commission that has
not been able for whatever
reason
to to operate I think at the standard
that all of us would like to see whether
it's a lack of resources a lack of Staff
a lack of money a lack of of rules
um with the suggestion that we have one
onone or non- quarm meetings we have a
right to no law and this legislative
body tries to follow the right to no no
we are not in what I would call the
blame game I don't care to blame anybody
that's not how we solve problems I don't
need a discussion of a list of this
person did this or that person did that
or this is the exception what I need is
a fully functioning agency that is
designed to best meet the needs of the
citizens and we as a
legislature do do not
administer the commission our job is to
set the
laws that then become the basis for how
the commission functions and they have
their regulations and they have whatever
else we are the policy committee we are
not the the people who should be
fine-tuning who should say well you know
maybe this person should do this instead
basic structure upon which we have made
it possible for the commission to do
what they're supposed to be doing and if
we don't don't do that we are not doing
our job and um and and the time has long
since P when we have to
acknowledge longstanding
difficulties and um and this not fight
out who struck
John um either in private or in public
but instead take major steps to solve
the problems because to solve well to
potentially solve one
problem in the midst of of a morass of
problems I
think does not help us get we're both
representative and Andrew and I and I
think all of you want to be I hope I
didn't talk too long no thank you for
your comments I appreciate it when I was
uh saying when
I agreed that hearing some suggestions
would be a good idea what I meant was
let legislative suggestions not one-off
suggestions what I meant was if there
was a deadline that we needed to put
into place that you know uh parties have
until XYZ date in order to file or give
XYZ so that they were more they weren't
going to be able to be waiting a year as
she just was discussing to give
something that was what I was referring
to not talking about specific instances
of specific things but a general picture
if there's something legislatively that
needed to be
fix it maybe would move something along
and I do acknowledge that I'm showing my
Prejudice and I do have Prejudice we all
do uh particular Prejudice that I want
to acknowledge is that I put a lot of
faith in the Integrity the
thoroughness the
honesty of the um of the LBA of both the
budget Division and the audit division
that comes from years of working closely
with them we as a legislature are very
lucky to have these incredible people
willing to do very hard work and
sometimes under unpleasant situations
where they have to
um pursue
answers
where people don't want to give them
people might not want to give the
answers and um and I and I understand
that but all of that is why I think
I don't want to be in the way of having
them do the most complete analysis
possible and then have us be able to say
this is an appropriate role for the
legislature to play I guess I'm an
old-fashioned person I happen to know
they three branches of government a lot
of people don't even know that they're
three branches of government um I happen
to know that um that there is an
executive branch that's
separate um and and I think we each have
our obligations perfect um and so I
haven't to be fair I haven't seen an LBA
report so can I ask do they typically
give recommendations on how to rectify
the situation or they do they just
report things that they saw okay I am
disappointed to hear that you who I
believe know everything there is to know
and Who as a freshman know more and have
done more than people who have been here
forever and ever like me if you haven't
seen an LBA report you are missing
something that a performance audit a
financial order is what you might expect
a performance audit is very different
they're all
online and you know LBA you go to the
audit division pick a topic that you're
interested in and go read it they will
give you a history how did the how did
the agency get formed for what purpose
what is the purpose of the audit
sometimes it's just for something small
sometimes it's more um inclusive as this
one is and then they go through what
they've observed they go through where
they see that what they observe differs
from what they would have expected
either because of the law or the rules
um and they go through what um the
suggestions for adjusting and they also
don't just drop that on the agency
because one of the most important parts
is the agency gets to respond to each of
those points to say well we didn't see
it this way or well we see that you're
right and we're going to try to do
something or um you know whatever they
can answer in any way they want but they
are not blindsided in any way and then
there is a checklist and one of the
things that's interesting to see is when
an agency has been um uh audited over a
period of time to see what they were
asked to do when they were audited it in
1996 U was that before you were born no
not quite um and um and H have they
accomplished that you know have they
accomplished it in part I mean this is
not just saying ah this is a a very
thorough and just for the fun of it
Madam chair you should go online and
pick anyone anyone at all I mean I'm not
going to say oh pick this one because
it's really good I'll definitely go look
I had only seen the financial ones I
hadn't seen so I didn't know that there
was two entirely different entirely
different people doing it and um highly
competent and um I mean if if you know
if there's anyone in the room who would
disagree with that
evaluation speak up um don't don't hold
back um so that is why uh
subcommittee chair mlan and why
representative D Lorenzo and I and put
so much faith in and because we can't do
it we don't have the skills and um nor
should we because that is not our
role and um that's my speech thank you I
appreciate it so it sounds like they'll
probably be presenting some suggestions
and you'll have time to respond back and
then afterwards I guess we'll as a as a
committee kind of look through those and
see if there might be anything we want
to move forward with and then definitely
um I know when I draft a bill I do talk
to the stakeholders involved with the
bill to make sure that I'm not missing
something so if if it was me I would
definitely be in touch if it's somebody
else they they'll likely do the same so
thank you I appreciate that
sure yes thank you madam chair I have
one question
who in this whole thing with the Human
Rights Commission follows through to
make
sure we don't drop the ball because it's
been going on for years and years and
nobody's done
anything and we go back to the same
thing as representative Smith is saying
we have to do something we just can't
keep going against the people of New
Hampshire
and the way I feel we're also wasting
money and I'm not blaming anybody in the
hum right commission it's just we got to
find out from the pro performance audit
what's going on but after we go through
all this who's going to carry the ball
you if nobody else has anything we'll go
ahead and close the hearing does anybody
else have anything no thank you all
thank you all for coming and for for
giving feedback uh throughout this
process we very much appreciate it thank
you
m